c'est le retour de cpnt ont osé sortir
des de la délégation ses pairs la pape
est sa flamme olympique de giratina
c'est la première c'est la toile y
rouler sur balles pour se détendre voilà
pour cette première c'est la flamme
olympique de triple play
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand même au sommet de la hype quoi là
alors on a passé alors je voulais
arriver et on a passé un cap j'ai pas
alors oui on va pas se mentir la même
moi je ne contrôle plus rien des jeunes
et des affaires je ne sais pas ce qui me
tombe sous la main à quoi je ne sais
plus elles sont aidées quatuor avec moi
je ne comprends plus bon je ne ça va
trop vite mais je crois qu'on démarre
cette saison trop haut trop vite trop
fort mais pas dans le dos bien
s'interroger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que professeur
c'est vraiment
bon soin
afin et psychiatre elle parle avec les
femmes donc si vous voulez vous est
génial comme ça vous prenez un rendez
vous chez elle
[Applaudissements]
c'est
là que celle où vous plaît je plais on
va accueillir le professeur à ou bon
choix professeur à vous merci d'être
avec nous ce soir merci beaucoup bonsoir
merci par les mots avec respect sans
insulter sans vous exciter et du
logement vous inquiétez pas on est tout
va bien se passer un professeur vraiment
on est très contents de vous en remercie
en tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ça vous touche ce genre de
liesse populaire autour de vous et de
voilà de soutien
écoutez moi je dis seulement mon vieux
maître me disais je préfère les
compliments au coût de nos fesses je
suis d'accord avec lui bon on est
d'accord moi aussi je vais vous dire la
vérité je ne regarde jamais la
télévision je n'écoute pas la radio je
lis pas les journaux alors je n'en sais
rien vous savez qui je suis
écoutez j'ai entendu votre nom mais je
connais à peine votre tête j'ai jamais
vu mon nom est plus beaux spas tête vous
avez le meilleur professeur et avec avec
emmanuel macron le président ça me fait
plaisir de vous faire rire exemple il ya
des choses dont je pense que
scientifiquement elles sont pas
raisonnables ouais c'est de dire que
quelqu'un qui a eu coville doit être
vacciné deux mois après alors ça ça n'a
aucune base scientifique j'ai mesuré
quel était le nombre de gens qui rechute
et donc il ya un taux de protection de
l'infection naturelle qui est plus de
99% il n'y a pas un vaccin au monde qui
fait ça donc de dire que quelqu'un qui a
fait un gros vide doit être vacciné deux
mois après c'est pas de la science sait
pas ce que c'est je sais pas d'où ça
sort mais c'est pas vrai merci en tout
cas professeur away mon père vous aime
beaucoup ça peut vous aider voilà
c'est important
le professeur ou tu es tu là tu as suivi
toutes ces suivis je n'écoute rien ne
m'a choqué dans ce qu'il a dit on si les
trouver comme on disait un instant plus
tôt posé j'arrive je trouve que je
laissais pendant dix ans que j'y connais
rien du tout comme vous d'ailleurs on
connaît tous rien du tout que l'on
est une sommité mondiale aurait même si
un administratif le mais en fait tu me
fais aucun souci pour son avenir il sera
demandé dans le monde entier il a
découvert des dizaines de virus il a
fait des milliers de publications là il
ya eu une polémique pourquoi la
polémique et mais vous êtes jamais
demandé pourquoi là que ces fameuses
hydroxy chloroquine je sais pas ce que
c'est que l'hydroxyde week-end chez que
j'en ai à la maison au cas où vous mais
bon
oui bah oui bien soigné avec quelque
chose et non mais là pour être soigné
par des médecins pas seulement les
vaccins l'autre le mot traitement n'a
pas été prononcé pendant des mois c'est
un peu énervant bon bref l'hydroxyde
chloroquine elle a été interdite en
france quand le lendemain de la
publication d'une étude baguette d'un
truc qui s'appelle landes 7
le ministère de la santé a sauté sur
cette étude qui démonte elle hydroxy
chloroquine a interdit l'hydroxyethyl le
lendemain d'études était tellement faux
ce que les auteurs même de l'étude ont
dit qu'elles étaient fausses j'ai pas
compris pourquoi le gouvernement n'avait
pas annulé son agent l'interdiction si
on va danser avec les régions on va donc
dansé sur des musiques régionales on va
découvrir à chaque fois ton partenaire
on va partir sur la première danse on
part dans les dom tom alors tu connais
bien c'est parti comme ça
sur la natte à lui marqué ses
partenaires très mature l'ormeau
[Applaudissements]
à
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
j'en perds tu
[Rires]
avais pas envie d'autres choses dans ta
vie ben j'allais à l'école et en même
temps je faisais ça donc c'est comme
l'argent de poche pour moi tu avais
d'autres potes qui faisaient ça ouais
t'as des peurs ou tu te disais de façon
je suis mineur je m'en fous mais voilà
c'est sûr que je suis mines a pas de
risque donc c'est ça donc en fait tu te
disais je m'en fous car des quatre
vingt huit ou ouais ouais combien de
fois deux fois c'est deux fois et ont
lâché au bout de combien temps 96 heures
de votre foi 24 heures non c'est pas de
l'argent facile m quand tu fais de
l'argent facile pas du tout mais quand
tu fais quand tu fais des tp de 10
heures quand tu fais de tp de 10h à
minuit de temps plein des temps plein
mais quand je fais de 10h à minuit et tu
prends ta paire minuit je te demande pas
que tu vas tu vendre le surnom merad l
ademe adam mair l'ademe alors on va on
va pas vous plaindre d merci c'est
d'asseoir la loi il ya des gens qui
travaillent à l'usiné corail 10h et qui
gagne 1200 euros par mois et qui
travaille comme comme des chiens je suis
sûr que gagner pas 1200 euros par mois
des deux fois plus deux fois plus vous
rendez compte là mais ils disent et
faible mentalement parce que c'est la
facilité qu'il a choisi moi j'ai grandi
entre les fossés gens les morineau la
cité du luth pour ceux qui connaissent
j'ai passé 28 ans dans un quartier égal
à chaque fois que j'étais travail à 15
ans et demi les mecs ils m'ont dit
arrête de faire qu'on était fûts de
bière tu fais pitié viens avec nous pour
d'idées pour faire chauffer à l'époque
c'était mille francs mille francs par
jour c est moi je touchais 5000
5100 francs c'était que dalle c'est dans
cinq jours je pouvais faire mon moi
mentale membres j'avais envie d'y
arriver mentalement je voulais que mes
parents ils soient fiers mentalement je
voulais être examinée garder je voulais
faire les choses tout seul la facilité
c'est d'aller faire les choses comme il
l'a dit lui c'est lui voulait das a cédé
ça c'est facile de le faire faut pas
dire tout à l'heure il a dit il ya moins
de risques il ya des risques de prendre
une balle dans la tête les mecs sont pas
dire aux jeunes n'y a pas de risque
vient d'être lancée dans les jours qui
suivent quand je te dis c'est la
facilité et je veux faire chef
d'entreprise stade de droite de jambes
faut aller travailler
je serai et bien pratiquement à l'entrée
d'accord du parcours est tout près il y
aura omar sy très bien que la lande la
police est prévenue pour saverdun oui
tout à cette altitude de terrain du mans
non et on a payé à angelina jolie
monique à l'agonie djabia
je connais ça va mourad pécho
203 galeries
oui
zut c'est
juste la coiffure c'est vrai que là
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la réalité c'est
à dire que je m'en fous pas d antibes
accéder ils font ce qu'ils veulent ils
ont droit passe ils n'ont pas envie de
se faire vacciner qu'ils se fassent
vacciner
mais qui applaudissent et les médecins
et les infirmières à la première vague
est ce que faisait partie des gens qui
les applaudissent eh oui ou non bah oui
oui comment ça se fait qu'aujourd'hui
les gens qui les applaudissent
aujourd'hui disent nous on veut pas
qu'ils aillent désengorger un petit peu
les hôpitaux publics pour ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens d'aller dans le privé
parce que les couloirs sont pleins
compris j'ai rien compris alors je tends
pas rien compris à temps
et nous on a compris
venant d'un misogyne franchement ça
m'embête un misogyne on sait si si on a
ce que
je fais ce que je veux c'est envie de
prendre des fiches prend des fiches
c'était juste que ce que j'aurais encore
maintenant en fait le problème tu l'as
mouvement mécanique est ce que je veux
c'est sur le sol et barres merci je ne
vais pas me dire que je dois faire on
n'est pas sur la télé réalité on est
chez cyril hanouna la non mais c'est
super attention à sa tête on connaît
leurs noms mais je vais te dire le vrai
problème où il est oui
100 millions d'euros levés neuf mille
lits si on n'avait pas fermé ses élites
aurait pas tant due aux urgences
[Applaudissements]
municipaux les pattes articulées en
train de dire non mais c'est le foot en
fait des autres mais n'ont jamais les
gens les gens qui va le sauver l'hôpital
c'est parce qu'il a dit bouder c'est
parce qu'il a dû passer par une guerre
monnières mondiaux en tout cas en
parlant de personnages qui ferait un
excellent candidat parité jean semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec 165 mille abonnés il avait semble
abonné dont dont je pense 120000 voilà
qui sont voilà qu'ils sont cons été
achetés en chine non vraiment des photos
[Musique]
ça c'est de la diffamation michel carnas
tout allait réactiver son compte non
[Applaudissements]
mais je le caresse vous avez une
dernière chose à dire à jean bessière a
écouté non voilà pas de ballons cette
année
en tout cas vraiment merci
c'est michel dit merci michel carrade
est devenu le meilleur garçon
fring dernière chose non non non merci
ont invité merci
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est michel candat standard
max
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]